the block is shut down on both sides by
NYPD and SWAT
the commissioner is like there's no way
all these people would be here this
aggressive trying to get a bunch of
sneakers I was like yeah I'm as confused
as you are
[Music]
what up GQ my name is Jeff staple I'm
the founder and creative director of
staple and this is my life in sneakers
I'm a child of the 70s born in New
Jersey to first generation immigrant
parents but there were no people that
looked like me in the middle of New
Jersey
one of like the commonalities I could
really relate with with other kids was
Sports particularly basketball and
Tennis at the time you know Mcenroe
Sampras Courier those days of like this
kind of like bad boy of tennis style
that was coming out was really dope to
me and then when Michael Chang hit the
scene it was like yo somebody looks like
me and is kicking ass like yes
these Gods whether it was like the goat
Michael Jordan Allen Iverson with the
Crossovers the only thing that we as
mere mortals could resonate with was the
thing on their feet something hit me in
my gut that these were pieces of Art and
not like a commodity item
[Music]
I had zero intention to start a fashion
brand I was a graphic design major my
path was get a job at an ad agency yes I
knew about these 10 brands that were in
the world that were like sold at a store
called Union in SoHo and I'm talking
like Futura had a brand stash had a
brand but I wasn't gonna be one of these
Brands like there's 12 of them in the
whole world and they're sold at this one
shop in the whole world like I didn't
think I deserved to be in that culture
I took inspiration from graffiti artists
who would paint their art and do their
tag on the side of subway trains versus
on a static wall strictly with the
purpose of getting it seen by as many
eyeballs as possible
and so I was thinking like man maybe
instead of on a paper I should print my
art on a shirt and then I could give
those to 10 of my friends and now when
they take the L train and the bus my art
is getting seen by thousands of people
every day that was such a subversive
thing to me as I was wearing one of my
shirts around in the triple five Soul
store which was in the Lower East Side I
walked in and the manager said yo that's
a cool shirt where'd you get that from
and I was like oh I made this shirt and
he was like damn if you make like a
dozen we'll put them in the shop if you
want and then Union the store that was
my Mecca the manager there caught wind
of these shirts selling at triple five
and he was like yo if you make a
separate design for us we'll take 12 as
well it was just me going to school at
Parsons breaking into school to print
these shirts and hustling 12 shirt
orders between these boutiques in
downtown New York City I mean that's as
the culture as you can get this is the
era of like people selling mixtapes and
CDs out of the back of their trunk
airbrushing art on the back of a denim
jacket and slinging that one at a time
me silk screening t-shirts hand
delivering them to these shops 12 at a
time you know like this was the birth of
Street culture as we know it today
[Music]
in the mid 90s fader magazine was
beginning a journey of becoming one of
the most influential lifestyle culture
Publications and media arms that ever
existed in my opinion really one of the
first that combined hip-hop Rock gaming
fashion all in one publication I was
designing every issue and I would pitch
stories that I'd want to write and being
that I was a sneakerhead I noticed there
was this phenomenon happening in the mid
90s Where Heads would go to Japan or go
to Hong Kong and they would buy back
shoes that were only available in Japan
or Hong Kong bring them back here in
America and sell them for like 25 bucks
above retail and then they would buy
sneakers in the Bronx Philly and DC and
then bring them back to Tokyo and Hong
Kong and do the same thing this was the
beginning of resale culture but it was
literally kids with empty duffel bags
carrying as much as they could inside
that duffel and transporting them back
and forth and I'm sitting here as a
sneaker head saying like damn if Nike is
this billion dollar organization and
they know the shoe that they're dropping
in Japan is highly covered in America
why wouldn't they just release it
globally why are they making us do this
cat and mouse game and so I pitched the
story to Rob Stone who's the publisher
of the fader I want you to send me to
Japan I'm going to meet with Nike Japan
and I'm going to ask them why they're
doing this and by the way I knew nobody
at Nike like I knew nothing I literally
hit the ground in Tokyo I went literally
from kids who worked at sneaker stores
to their manager to their buyer to the
salesperson that they dealt with at Nike
to their district manager to the point
where I finally got in touch with Mr
Marcus tayui the one guy at Nike Japan
we had a great interview at Nike Japan
headquarters like just meet kid from New
York from streetwear manages to get to
Japan and I'm sitting at his office in
Nike Japan like I've already won the
game in my mind like I'm like yo I'm
done I'm sitting at Nike and in the
interview he's like wait so let me get
this straight you designed the fader you
write you're a sneakerhead obviously and
you have this brand called staple that
like is sort of Catching Fire in New
York I was like yeah he's like we need
to be working together I was like yes
yes
[Music]
the white dunk anniversary was coming
and they were gonna dedicate different
dunks to different key cities in sneaker
culture and Marcus calls me up on my
landline telephone I'm like hello and
he's like Jeff it's Marcus would you be
interested in designing the dunk that is
dedicated to the city of New York it
didn't click immediately for me that oh
I'm putting the pigeon on the dunk we
actually explored Statue of Liberty dunk
or Empire State Building after like
maybe the seventh round it was like wait
pigeon on the dunk could that work and
then of course people were like who the
would wear a pigeon flying Vermin
rat on their feet like no that's the way
to get people to never want to touch the
shoe but I love that everyone hated them
because actually everyone hated me
people in the industry were like you're
this Chinese kid from New Jersey what
you come from a rich billionaire China
no there was just haters everywhere and
I felt like pigeons were like hated on
as well to me a pigeon really represents
the unloved Underdog Hustler of New York
City I said I want to make a shoe that
if you live in Jersey Connecticut or
Philly you don't understand what I mean
I want to make a shoe for New York by
New York and New Yorkers will look at it
and be like I get it and they're like
all right we trust you we we don't get
it but we trust that when we put this
out true New Yorkers will understand
what you mean
February 22nd 2005 we released the
pigeon dunk at this point like sneaker
lineups aren't really a thing yet like
campouts weren't a thing there were
probably two other shoes in history that
had a camp out at this point I remember
the night of the 21st when I left the
store that night there was maybe like 50
kids online all well behaved I bought
them pizzas because it was like freezing
cold and I said yeah I'll see you guys
tomorrow right come back down the next
day 10 A.M
the block is shut down on both sides by
NYPD and SWAT
the commissioner is like on the
megaphone who owns read space like and
I'm like uh me they're like come over
here what are you doing like he thought
I was selling drugs out the space or
something like that I was like no we're
selling a sneaker and he's just like
there's no way all these people would be
here this aggressive on a morning like
overnight trying to get a bunch of
sneakers I was like yeah I'm as confused
as you are when the crowd sort of
cleared and the cops finally got some
control we saw on the ground that they
were like baseball bats and knives and
we even saw a machete like a legit
crocodile dundee-sized machete just
people came prepared to get the shoes by
any means necessary which was a scary
situation I'm glad it didn't go there
the NYPD really helped they let kids who
finally got the shoe be escorted out the
back door they actually called the taxi
and limousine service to have New York
taxis lined about the back so that kids
could go straight into the taxi and get
out of the Les and I remember one kid
was like I have no more money I spent
all my money on these dunks and I saw
the cop be like here's five dollars tell
the taxi driver to go as far away as you
can on the next morning it was
unbeknownst to me on the front page of
the New York Post and covered frankly by
CBS News Fox News NBC news on like the
evening news too sneaker lineups might
have happened a handful of times this
was the first time that it was like
national news overnight
GQ you asked me to list my top five
sneakers
the Nike SB pigeon dunk the OG this is
the one that I would say for many people
put my name on the map it's actually a
dangerous thing to wear these shoes like
from an asset protection standpoint like
I will get I will get Merced if I get
these on my feet I do appreciate that
there's only you know 300 in the world
and I also don't believe that Nike and I
should ever re-release this which was on
the table like high up on the list we
collectively decided that this deserves
to be like Raiders of the Lost Ark like
let's just leave it as it is forever as
a grill
because of that decision to not
re-release the original pigeon dog we've
done other iterations of pigeon dunks
most recently we did the panda dunk
which is my homage to my people and my
culture so going back full circle of
that story of being the underappreciated
unknown Asian kid I did this shoe with
the panda representation and I dropped
the shoe first in China
last in New York city so this was my
Songbird to my OG culture and giving
something back to the motherland
underneath in the outsole here you have
the original headline from the OG pigeon
dunk to just you know connect it back
Full Circle A lot of people ask why the
outside swoosh is white and the inside
Solutions Gray
the gray comes straight from the OG
pigeon dunk so you get a little bit of
that DNA in here as well so this is one
of my Grails as well one of my top five
and then the special packaging in the
bamboo box is really beautiful too again
all with the Chinese characters to
remark back to the Homeland
[Music]
another part of my top five the Nordic
pack the true heads will know that like
before the pigeon dunk there was an Air
Force One and a dunk that I did this was
part of when I was just doing like
design work for Nike the idea was to do
a winter Olympic inspired pack where you
have like these walls and these sort of
like Nordic themes with the quilting and
everything and then what's cool is like
if you look on the inside of the shoe
we even did like sort of like the
insoles have like this US map with like
different cities that the Winter
Olympics were in like so this is Japan
and this is just always one of my
favorites I love the laces on it and it
just reminds me of the time pre pigeon
dunk of how simple sneaker culture was
[Music]
this is low-key one of my favorite
projects that I've ever done with Nike
so this is the Nike Considered boot this
was Nike's first foray into a completely
sustainable environmentally friendly
shoe meaning that there are no glues
used to make this shoe all the leather
is veg tan you know there's like no
chemicals used to make this shoe and I
actually named Nike Considered Nike
Considered it's my name
when they came to me it was called Nike
Ecotec and I was like that's a terrible
name and so they were like okay help us
think of a new name so what I did was I
wrote a Manifesto for what should be
considered Nike Ecotec and I said all
these things like consider the Earth
consider the future consider you know
like all the stuff I wrote this whole
Manifesto and so Nike Considered was my
name and my brainchild and just working
with this really Renegade team at Nike
of like seven other people but this era
of Nike Considered was just one of the
Great Moments of sneaker design for me
[Music]
finally it's the Air Jordan 3 black
cement obviously in a time where before
Brands and streetwear Brands were
getting collabs left and right the idea
that Michael Jordan would sit down with
Tinker Hatfield and create a shoe
completely from scratch that wasn't
derived from anything before that was to
me one of the first and best truest
collaborations of all time if you
remember the Jordan 1 before this was
essentially a dunk the two was this like
made in Italy's strange anomaly that
didn't sell anywhere and then they came
back with the three and this was the
shoe that when I saw this I thought this
is Art I was obsessed with the shoe this
was the first shoe that I really took
care of and I remember this white on the
back of the heel would always get worn
off and I would take white out and
meticulously paint the white back I
would like scrub all the Pebbles out of
the outsole and everything and my mom
and dad are just like why are you
treating this shoe like it's this like
religious artifact I don't know why
either it just did something to me this
to me was the shoe that turned me into a
sneaker head this is it we're gonna go
from five to three you gotta get rid of
two of them okay all right
if I had to go from what I selected down
to three it would be these three these
are my top three
take away one of them top two okay
top two right here
let's kill the baby
oh this is so hard
this is the one that started
me as a sneakerhead this is the one that
made me
oh
I'm gonna have to go with the with the
the Genesis this is the Genesis without
this there is no that you know so I'm
gonna have to go with this you win taker
why would title for your book not just
news we were trying to think of all
these other clever titles for the book
and I remember my publishing Partners
said you know based on our metadata and
like keywords that are searchable on
Instagram the word sneaker really needs
to be in the title and I was like damn
it I don't want it to just be about
sneakers and so I was like wait a second
it's Jeff staple not just sneakers there
sneakers is a title for your keywords
but it also says what I wanted to say
which is that sneakers is a byproduct of
who I am not the reason for my whole
existence where I've already gone is
crazy like I've gone 10 000 steps
further than I would have ever thought
that I've gone what I want to position
myself now is that of a teacher this is
what I've learned in the 25 years of
coming up through this and how can I
make it so that the culture lives and
breathes further even Beyond me there is
a competitive side of me where I want to
be the best I want to be number one and
I want to be the greatest but I don't
want to be the greatest in a single
lonely room what is the thing that
Define you that you think the world
needs to know about and you need to get
out of you wear that on your sleeve
don't look around don't look left right
don't look on Instagram and Tick Tock
and be like I want to do exactly what
they do because it's not going to work
the beautiful thing about the world that
we live in today is that there's a
Marketplace for all of y'all like no
matter how weird obscure or random you
think you are there are a hundred
thousand people out there in the world
that will back you and your phone now
gives you access to those hundred
thousand people you know so go out there
and find them